[Musique]
il a réagi à l'annoncé de sa convocation
forcé comme témoin au procès dit des
sondages de l'elysée moi j
je ne réponds pas aux provocations et je
ne veux pas polémiquer le juge a en
effet ordonné qu'il soit amené devant le
tribunal à la force publique le 2
novembre il ya déjà bien assez de
problèmes dans le pays c'est pas la
peine de faire un problème
inutile revoilà françois hollande alors
une rentrée médiatique à la sulfateuse
avant une tournée en france pour la
promotion d'un livre de 300 pages
intitulé affronter emmanuel macron est
décrit comme un homme d' aucune doctrine
un voyageur sans boussole changeant
d'opinion gré des événements sautant
d'une conviction à l'autre comme une
grenouille sur des nénuphars en sol on
nous a habitués depuis quatre ans à être
très critique vis-à-vis du président de
la république du gouvernement pour des
raisons qui lui appartiennent il n'a pas
la seule responsabilité de la situation
puisque à droite comme à gauche il n'y a
pas eu la préparation d'une alternative
ce qui fait que les populismes et on en
voit ici les éléments les plus dangereux
françois hollande qui parle d' eric
zemmour évidemment comme d'un petit
chose qui nourrissait une amertume
grandissante de ne pas être suffisamment
reconnus mais n'est pas trump qui veut
oui ce petit show fond c'est quand même
sacrément et jusqu'à présent il était
amène un amuseur un peu un peu
inquiétant sur les plateaux de
télévision et devient un candidat à
l'élection présentielle et bientôt
impossible figurant au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle vous n'y
croyez pas
oui ces coups là
couture et culex
hercules et
comment une heure après la photo sarah
knafo la plus proche conseillère de
zemmour s'agace
là
[Musique]
je
tu vas pas te mettre à profit
presque immédiatement la réaction sur
les réseaux sociaux de la ministre
marlène schiappa
visé des journalistes avec une arme en
leur disant reculer n'est pas drôle
c'est horrifiant surtout après avoir dit
sérieusement vouloir réduire le pouvoir
des médias elle chaque pas est une
imbécile voilà ce que je lui réponds
qu'elle est grotesque et ridicule elle
essaye de chercher
à monter en neige une polémique
grotesque tous les français vont se
moquer d'elle et c'est pas la première
fois et son récit qui est un récit et
qui est qui et qui parle un certain
nombre de gens et et arrested dangereux
pour notre pays me suffit pas de crier
aux fascistes ou de dire comme je
l'avais écrit que c'est un danger
seulement ce qui me semble assez nouveau
dans la séquence récente c'est la
vigueur de ces attaques visent à vis de
son propre camp de ses propres amis
tant et si bien qu'à un moment on finit
par se dire il n'y a pas grand monde qui
trouve grâce aux yeux de françois
hollande si ce n'est françois hollande
jean luc mélenchon lui est un boulet
pour la gauche oui c'est un fardeau pour
la gauche il refuse toute alliance il
prend des positions qui empêche tout
programme commun vouloir une sixième
république mais laquelle arnaud
montebourg comme un zorro de la
politique surgissant hors de la nuit
pour délivrer la france des griffes de
bruxelles il en est même arrivé à être
d'accord avec les positions polonaise
sur la suprématie du droit national par
rapport au droit européen un tir de
missile balistique depuis un sous-marin
la corée du nord poursuit sa course à
l'armement et augmente sa capacité
militaire suscitant la crainte de la
communauté internationale un essai issus
d'une technologie très avancée est
détecté par la corée du sud c'est une
épée qui datent des croisades elle a été
retrouvée par un israélien samedi
dernier lors d'une sortie plongée
la découverte a été faite dans les eaux
de la mer méditerranée